hi this is sal khan of the khan academy
and i just wanted to let all of you know
about a really exciting challenge that's
going on it applies to any student that
is between the ages of 13 and 18 years
old anywhere in the world and so if
you're one of them you should definitely
listen to this
but if you know anyone between ages of
13 and 18 this could be life-changing
for them so you should also listen and
then tell them about it so i'm talking
about is the breakthrough junior
challenge and you can learn more about
it at breakthrough
juniorchallenge.org but it's a
partnership that we have with the
breakthrough prize the breakthrough
prize is essentially like a new nobel
prize for people making breakthroughs in
math science uh major contributions to
humanity and as part of this the
breakthrough junior challenge is all
about young people between the ages of
13 and 18 creating videos that explain
something about the universe that we
didn't either we didn't appreciate
before or know before or something that
we didn't know but explaining it in a in
a pretty cool profound approachable
maybe funny way and this is a really
really really really really
big deal the winner of this prize is
going to get a 250
000
scholarship yes that is four zeros after
the two five two hundred and fifty
thousand dollar scholarship so it'll
pretty much pay for uh any college out
there the winner of last year's prize
ryan chester he is now able to go
to college on this 250 000
scholarship and he got into harvard and
i i could imagine that winning this
prize was a good part of his of his
application but that's not just where
that's not where it ends there's going
to be a hundred thousand dollar lab
four-year school a hundred thousand
dollar science lab and fifty thousand
dollars for your teacher so all in we're
talking about four hundred thousand
dollars
a video that's going to be five minutes
or less that explains something in an
interesting way and i really want to
point out this doesn't have to be
something with uh fancy special effects
or graphics you can look at some of the
finalists from last year look at ryan
chester's videos we really care about
how it's explained and the content it
could be a video like a con khan academy
style video where it could be just a
background and and some writing with
maybe a few visuals it could be you at a
chalkboard or it could be a little bit
more produced it could be some live
action whatever else but the key is is
it explains something in math or science
in a novel way in an interesting way and
someone out there listening is going to
win this and it's going to be a
life-changing event and more than just
the money and the opportunities that are
going to open up it's really the chance
to help the world because the whole
reason why this prize exists is because
we think that young people
can look at the world in a different way
in a way that maybe people who've been
in in the field for a long time
won't see it and by looking at it in a
different way and explaining concepts
it'll open up all of our minds and
potentially even move the field forward
and above and beyond that
outside of the money outside of helping
the world which is really a really big
deal
the winners of the prize are going to
come to silicon valley come out here for
the breakthrough prize ceremony they're
going to get the ceremony on they're
going to get their prize on stage
alongside
leaders in their field
it's going to be nationally televised
there's all sorts of celebrities from
the silicon valley and hollywood that
are going to be there you should look at
some of the videos from uh previous
breakthrough prizes it's really a big
deal i i bought a tuxedo just for this
event so you could imagine it's a i
don't own a lot of formal wear so once
again if you're interested and you
really should be because it's not about
production value it's about ideas
creativity humor
and you're between ages 13 and 18 the
deadline is october 10th so it's about
three weeks from when i'm making this
video right now go to breakthrough
juniorchallenge.org
i think you'd be surprised this could be
life-changing for you
and remember five minutes max for the
video